-Chirinne Ardakani,
vous êtes
franco-iranienne, avocate,
membre d'Iran justice,
créé en septembre 2022
pour alerter sur les crimes
du régime des mollahs à la suite
du meurtre de Mahsa Amini,
cette jeune Kurde
iranienne de 22 ans,
tuée pour avoir
mal porté le foulard.
Quel est vraiment
le rôle de ce collectif ?
-Ce collectif
s'est créé au lendemain
de la mort de Mahsa Amini
qui a été vraiment
assassinée
par la police des moeurs.
L'objectif de ce collectif,
c'est ce que font tous les avocats,
en définitive, c'est défendre,
là, en l'occurrence,
une cause,
la cause des femmes iraniennes
et surtout de collecter les preuves
qui vont mettre au jour
la responsabilité
des auteurs de...
...d'arrestations arbitraires
de manifestants iraniens,
de viols en détention
et de faire un travail
de recensement de ces horreurs,
de ces crimes pour un jour pouvoir,
peut-être, traduire les auteurs
devant les juridictions
internationales.
-Chaque document
est donc sourcé, recoupé,
répertorié,
au fond, à 500 km de Téhéran,
vous vous autosaisissez
au nom des avocats qui, en Iran,
ne peuvent pas le faire.
-Tout à fait.
On travaille par substitution
à nos confrères empêchés.
Les avocats ne peuvent pas
défendre leurs clients.
Ils sont assimilés
à la cause de leurs clients.
Prenez l'exemple de Nasrin Sotoudeh,
avocate qui a défendu
un certain nombre de femmes
qui étaient des mal voilées.
Eh bien, Nasrin Sotoudeh a fait
l'objet d'arrestations,
elle a été condamnée
pour des atteintes
à la sécurité nationale,
pour avoir encouragé ces femmes.
C'est ce qu'on lui reprochait
en définitive,
pour avoir uniquement exercé
son métier, défendre les Iraniennes.
-Elle a été condamnée.
Une autre de vos confrères,
Maryam Arvin a été, elle,
retrouvée morte deux mois
après sa sortie de prison.
Au fond, défendre la liberté
en Iran, aujourd'hui,
c'est risquer la mort ?
-Tout à fait. C'est le propre
des régimes autocratiques.
On le voit,
les confrères ukrainiens,
certains
des confrères russes qui,
en solidarité
avec leurs confrères ukrainiens,
ont dénoncé
un certain nombre d'exactions,
on le voit également
au cas syrien.
Les régimes autocratiques
s'attaquent
aux objecteurs de conscience.
Les avocats en font partie.
Ils défendent
les libertés publiques,
les libertés individuelles.
Les journalistes en font partie,
Les intellectuels,
les universitaires.
C'est le propre
des régimes dictatoriaux
de cibler, de traquer
ces objecteurs de conscience.
-En Iran, on appelle les avocats
"les intermittents de la prison".
Vous connaissez
cette blague iranienne :
"Un détenu demande
à voir son avocat.
"Dans une cellule,
quelqu'un répond : 'Je suis là.'"
-Tout à fait.
Je crois que, précisément,
ce qu'attendent nos confrères,
c'est qu'on fasse ce travail
pour eux.
Il y a, au sein
de la profession d'avocat,
une grande solidarité.
C'est une forme de camaraderie.
D'ailleurs, madame la Bâtonnière,
Julie Couturier,
qui est très engagée
sur la question, précisément,
des confrères empêchés,
des confrères arrêtés,
le dit toujours :
"Il y a une blague qui circule.
"Quand un avocat se trouve
en détention
"quelque part dans le monde,
"il appelle le Bâtonnier de Paris."
C'est une forme d'expression
qui vient dire que les avocats
sont tous solidaires.
Où qu'on se trouve dans le monde,
on pourra
toujours avoir nos pairs
qui se mobilisent pour nous.
-Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
la profession d'avocat en Iran
est en voie de disparition ?
C'est celle
qui est le plus réprimée.
-Je dirais pas qu'elle est en voie
de disparition, au contraire.
Je dirais
qu'elle est très mobilisée.
Il faut comprendre
que la société civile iranienne
est très mobilisée.
Elle est organisée.
Il n'y a pas de parti politique.
Il y a un parti unique.
Il n'y a aucune liberté publique,
donc pas de liberté d'association.
Néanmoins, il y a une société civile
très forte.
Les avocats se mobilisent
dans leurs réseaux d'avocats.
Les soignants se mobilisent.
On a vu des médecins
qui allaient prodiguer des soins
au domicile des manifestants
qui étaient blessés
parce que les hôpitaux,
par exemple,
ne sont pas des lieux sûrs.
On voit que la société civile
se mobilise
par corps professionnels
et les avocats prennent leur part.
Ils ne le font pas
au grand jour
car la répression
est toujours là,
mais ce sont eux
qui nous sollicitent,
qui font des rapports
sur les droits humains,
qui vont eux-mêmes identifier
lesquels de leurs clients
sont en danger.
C'est dans le cadre
de cette coopération
entre professionnels
qu'avance la cause des Iraniens.
-Un étudiant en médecine,
d'après France Info,
a passé 21 jours en prison
pour avoir soigné
les pro-manifestants.
Il a eu son annulaire tranché
par la police au cutter.
Ces histoires sont courantes ?
-Oui, tout à fait.
Il faut bien comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui, en Iran,
le moindre signe
de soutien aux manifestants,
eh bien, est...
...est considéré
par les autorités
comme étant un acte subversif,
un acte d'hostilité à l'égard
de la république islamique.
-La "guerre contre Dieu"
ou "corruption sur Terre"
sont souvent
invoqués par le régime des mollahs
pour caractériser
les faits reprochés
aux manifestants.
Dieu a le dos large,
quand même.
-Dieu a le dos large
surtout dans une théocratie.
C'est-à-dire
que la particularité du système
de la république islamique,
c'est la confusion absolue
entre le pouvoir religieux civil.
D'ailleurs, la justice
est une justice duale.
Nous avons
les juridictions de droit commun
et les juridictions
révolutionnaires,
les fameux tribunaux
révolutionnaires
qui sont à la main
des religieux.
Quand le juge est un homme,
finalement, du clergé,
eh bien, les chefs d'accusation
sont des chefs d'accusation
religieux
hérités du droit islamique,
ou de l'interprétation
qui est faite du droit islamique.
Ca nous donne un florilège
de flots d'accusations
qui sont "guerre contre Dieu",
"inimitié à l'égard de Dieu"
"mohareb",
"corruption sur terre".
C'est très contingent
car ce sont des fourre-tout
qui disqualifient
politiquement les opposants.
Il se passe quoi
dans ces tribunaux ?
Le règne de l'arbitraire ?
-Tout à fait.
C'est une justice aux ordres.
Evidemment,
les dés sont pipés.
Les droits de la défense
ne sont évidemment pas respectés.
-Ils sont même niés.
-Tout à fait.
On a des comparants
qui comparaissent sans avocat.
qui ne connaissent même pas
les charges
dont ils sont prévenus,
qui sont condamnés au terme
de procès qui sont des simulacres
de procès.
-Des audiences en 3 minutes.
-Oui, pour des motifs graves,
des crimes passibles
de la peine de mort.
-Et aussi des avocats aux ordres
avec des listes d'avocats.
-C'est précisément là
qu'on se rend compte
que les barreaux indépendants,
ça n'existe finalement pas.
Dans certains pays,
on a des avocats
qui sont à la solde,
effectivement, de l'Etat
avec des barreaux,
des ordres professionnels
qui sont véritablement infiltrés
par les agents du régime.
Quand vous avez un juge aux ordres,
un avocat aux ordres,
ça nous donne une justice aux ordres
et une justice politique
qui est là pour neutraliser
la dissidence
et exécuter quiconque se heurte
au régime islamique.
-Le régime ne ciblerait pas
les jeunes des beaux quartiers,
mais avant tout les ouvriers
et les classes populaires
qui n'ont pas les moyens
de se défendre
ni de famille pour les aider ?
-C'est effectivement
ce que nous avons pu constater,
notamment avec les exécutés
et les condamnés à mort.
A chaque fois que des jeunes gens
avaient été exécutés,
c'était des jeunes gens
issus de catégories modestes
qui n'avaient pas les appuis
dans la société pour pouvoir
prendre le relais,
être leur porte-voix.
C'était les déshérités.
On avait un certain nombre
de fils d'ouvriers,
de très jeunes manifestants
qui ont malheureusement
été exécutés.
On se rend compte,
qu'il y a véritablement, en plus,
une justice de classe
dans la république islamique.
Je pense que c'est d'ailleurs
ce qui est assez frappant.
L'ayatollah Khomeini,
quand il arrive au pouvoir en 79,
il explique que ça va être
le défenseur des déshérités.
On le voit,
c'est une contradiction absolue.
-Près de 800 jeunes filles
ont été intoxiquées
au gaz dans les écoles et collèges
depuis le début
du soulèvement pour doucher
leurs ardeurs manifestantes.
Vous en avez été saisie
de ces dossiers-là ?
-Oui. Il y a des groupes de travail,
aujourd'hui,
qui se sont montés
avec des biologistes,
un certain nombre d'universitaires
qui font un travail, là encore,
de collecte de preuves.
Je disais tout à l'heure :
"La société civile est mobilisée
en corps professionnels."
Les avocats, médecins,
universitaires, biologistes
font leur travail.
-Une difficulté
quand on est loin,
c'est de vérifier la véracité
de ces preuves.
-Moi, je ne suis évidemment pas
journaliste sur la vérification,
par exemple, des sources.
Il y a un certain nombre de contenus
qui nous arrivent, des vidéos,
des photos, des liens.
C'est très difficile.
-Comment vous les jugez fiables ?
-Ca, ce n'est pas notre travail.
Nous, on collecte, on inventorie,
on archive aussi pour l'histoire
parce qu'il y aura un moment,
cette question
du dépérissement des preuves.
On l'a vu avec certains procès,
les procès de Nuremberg.
La question devenait difficile
avec le temps,
les preuves dépérissent.
Le travail, c'est d'archiver,
inventorier.
Un jour, des juridictions
se prononceront
pour savoir si les preuves
que nous avons récoltées
sont fiables,
avérées, corroborées et ce sera
au banc de la défense
de venir soutenir
que les preuves que nous fournissons
ne sont pas des preuves fiables.
-Vous allez déposer plainte
en France contre Hussein Salami,
chef des gardiens de la révolution.
Où en est la plainte
et à quoi va-t-elle servir ?
-Pour être très exacte, la plainte
que nous sommes en train de préparer
vise des propos,
un certain nombre de propos.
De décembre, grosso modo,
à mars 2023,
les hauts dignitaires,
et notamment les pasdaran,
n'ont pas été avares
de déclarations tonitruantes
à l'égard
des dissidents politiques
en Iran et à l'étranger.
Ils ont ciblé des militants
des droits humains.
C'est une pratique courante
des pasdaran
que d'aller faire des rapts,
même à l'étranger,
d'enlever un certain nombre
de dissidents politiques.
Par exemple, la militante féministe
Masih Alinejad,
nonobstant le fait
qu'elle soit aux Etats-Unis,
à des milliers de kilomètres,
elle a fait l'objet
d'une tentative d'assassinat.
Donc, notre plainte vise à saisir
le procureur de la République
d'un certain nombre de déclarations
qui étaient de véritables fatwas
à l'égard des membres
de la diaspora,
y compris ici, en France,
puisque le général Salami
a mis en garde les dissidents
en expliquant
que peu importe
où ils se trouvaient dans le monde,
la "main de Dieu"
allait s'abattre sur eux,
dans la même veine,
finalement,
que la fatwa qui avait été édictée
à l'encontre de Salman Rushdie
et on a bien vu que ces menaces
étaient à prendre au sérieux.
-C'est une façon
de protéger la diaspora iranienne ?
-Protéger la diaspora,
mais aussi surtout rappeler
que nos valeurs,
en tout cas en République
et de ce côté du monde libre,
c'est qu'on ne peut pas tout dire,
on ne peut pas menacer impunément,
on ne peut pas édicter
des fatwas,
on ne peut pas menacer de mort
les partisans de la liberté,
donc c'est défendre nos valeurs
que de dire que les journalistes,
qui ont été ciblés par cette fatwa
du général Salami,
on a vu que vos confrères
de Charlie Hebdo
avaient aussi été mis en garde,
c'est de défendre nos valeurs.
-L'ombre de Téhéran
plane sur la diaspora.
Comme eux, vous vivez dans la peur,
ça fait partie du job ?
-Alors, non, personnellement,
je ne vis pas dans la peur.
Je crois que les militants
des droits humains non plus.
Bien au contraire,
nous sommes, en réalité,
galvanisés
par les événements
et je crois
que nous sommes surtout animés
de l'espoir, car ce qui est certain,
c'est que ce régime finira
par tomber.
On a une jeune génération qui...
C'est le cas, par exemple,
des étudiants qui sont massés
devant l'université
de Téhéran,
qui disent non
à la république islamique.
Ils ont lancé une campagne du non.
Un certain nombre d'artistes
français dont Marjane Satrapi
se sont fait l'écho
de cette campagne.
Cette génération,
de toute façon,
mettra un terme
à la république islamique.
-La transition
est toute trouvée.
Des voix comme celle
de Marjane Satrapi,
de Golshifteh Farahani
et Zar Amir Ebrahimi,
prix d'interprétation féminine
à Cannes en 2022,
ce sont des soutiens
non négligeables
dans ce combat pour la liberté ?
-Oui, tout à fait.
D'une part, parce que ce sont
des visages connus en Occident :
elles incarnent aussi
par leur liberté
de création artistique,
et parce que ce sont des femmes
qui ont fait l'objet,
dans leur chair, dans leur histoire,
des tabous
qui règnent
dans la société iranienne
et qui ont été opprimées
en qualité
d'actrices,
en qualité d'artistes,
puisque l'une et l'autre
ont dû fuir l'Iran,
parce que les mollahs iraniens
ne concevaient pas
que des femmes pouvaient tourner
dans des films occidentaux...
-Sans être voilées.
-Sans être voilées,
avaient un rapport tout à fait libre
à la sexualité, aux autres
et pouvaient, comme ça,
libérer leur puissance créative.
Je crois
que c'est très symbolique
que ce soient des femmes puissantes
dans leur expression artistique
qui aujourd'hui
se fassent le porte-voix
des femmes iraniennes.
-Comment faire pour que la justice
passe en Iran
depuis l'étranger ?
Il y aurait moyen de saisir
la Cour pénale internationale ?
-Nous sommes...
Il est tout à fait...
-Sachant que l'Iran
ne reconnaît pas
la compétence du tribunal.
-Ces voies sont possibles,
mais nous ne sommes pas dupes
des difficultés.
Nous savons
que c'est un temps long,
qu'il faut le volontarisme des Etats
qui sont partis à la CPI.
Ce sont des processus
qui n'aboutiront pas
avant des décennies.
Nous en sommes très conscients.
Je crois qu'il faut aussi se dire
qu'indépendamment de la question
de la justice rendue,
il y a la question
de la volonté de justice.
Je prends cet exemple :
les mères aujourd'hui éplorées,
celles qui ont vu
leurs enfants exécutés,
notamment la famille
de Mahsa Amini,
mais pas que, un certain nombre
de mères, aujourd'hui,
réclament justice pour ces enfants
très jeunes qui ont été arrachés.
Des vies arrachées sans raison,
arbitrairement.
Je crois que c'est une demande forte
de la société iranienne,
la justice pour le peuple iranien.
-Comment peut s'exercer
cette justice-là ?
-Cette justice s'exercera
en temps utile.
Je vous l'ai dit,
c'est un temps long.
Les avocats que nous sommes
font ce travail
de recensement des preuves
et comme les procès de Nuremberg,
pour la mémoire,
je pense qu'au moment
où la société iranienne
sera débarrassée
des mollahs iraniens,
peut-être même que la justice
sera rendue
par le peuple iranien lui-même.
Je le dis souvent.
Les avocats que nous sommes,
finalement, on prépare juste
les preuves et peut-être qu'un jour,
on les donnera à nos confrères
et eux iront plaider
dans les juridictions iraniennes
la cause des Iraniens.
-Vous avez reçu le soutien
de parlementaires français.
100 ont accepté de parrainer
des manifestants condamnés à mort.
Vous avez évoqué
la répression en cours
au Conseil des droits de l'homme
des Nations Unies.
C'est symbolique,
ou la médiatisation est
une arme de dissuasion massive ?
-Alors, ce sont,
effectivement,
des actions qui sont symboliques,
mais pas que.
Moi, je crois en la mobilisation
de la société civile.
Je l'ai dit,
en Iran,
il n'y a pas de partis politiques,
il y a véritablement
une interdiction
des partis politiques.
Il n'y a pas d'expression publique
possible pour les journalistes.
La presse est aux ordres.
Dans ce contexte-là,
c'est aux citoyens engagés
dans les sociétés démocratiques
de se faire le porte-voix.
Quand on est
dans une société démocratique
comme en France,
on doit se saisir des outils
de la mobilisation, de nos élus,
nos parlementaires,
des médias occidentaux
qui sont des médias libres.
On se rend bien compte
que quand les médias
sont aux ordres,
quand les journalistes
sont empêchés de faire leur travail,
c'est un coup
pour la démocratie.
C'est aux citoyens engagés
que nous sommes
d'aller chercher
les outils dans nos sociétés
pour les mettre à disposition
des Iraniens
qui eux ne peuvent pas jouir
de ces outils de mobilisation.
-Sait-on combien il y a
de condamnés à mort aujourd'hui ?
-Tout à fait.
En tout cas,
pour des motifs politiques,
on est à plus d'une centaine
aujourd'hui
qui sont dans les couloirs
de la mort,
qui risquent une exécution à l'aube,
dont la peine a été confirmée,
qu'ils n'ont plus
de voie de recours,
dont on sait
qu'ils sont voués
à l'exécution
et à la pendaison,
puisque c'est le régime
qu'ont choisi les autorités
pour exécuter
les manifestants.
C'est à peu près
une centaine de personnes,
mais en réalité,
on n'en sait jamais trop rien.
Il n'y a pas de listing,
il y a des centres d'interrogatoire,
de détention cachés, secrets, voilà.
On n'a pas de certitudes.
De notre recensement,
il y a plus
d'une centaine de personnes
dans les couloirs de la mort.
-J'imagine que le régime
a tout intérêt à garder le flou
sur les chiffres exacts
pour terroriser
la population.
-Tout à fait,
et en même temps,
le régime se nourrit
de cette terreur
qu'il va distiller
dans la population
pour l'empêcher
de descendre dans la rue.
C'est de la terreur de masse.
-Une guerre psychologique.
-Oui, c'est une guerre des nerfs,
psychologique.
Je me souviens de tous les militants
des droits humains
que nous étions en décembre
quand les exécutions
arrivaient au compte-gouttes.
C'était épouvantable.
Tous les matins,
les Iraniens se réveillaient
en regardant sur les réseaux sociaux
pour savoir si leurs proches
avaient été pendus à l'aube.
C'était une véritable
guerre psychologique
et qui vise,
en réalité,
à ce que les gens restent chez eux
par peur du régime.
-Que pouvez-vous faire
pour stopper cette répression
et cette vague d'exécutions ?
Est-ce que vous avez
les moyens ?
-Le premier des moyens,
c'est de continuer d'en parler,
de faire
ce que vous faites :
faire vivre ce sujet iranien.
Le sujet iranien, plus largement,
nous touche tous,
parce qu'il promeut des valeurs
qui sont universelles.
Cette bannière
est extrêmement forte :
"Femme, vie, liberté".
Cette devise est universelle
et nous parle à tous, où qu'on soit.
C'est une célébration des femmes,
de ce qu'elles représentent
dans la société.
Les femmes ont été aux avant-gardes
du mouvement iranien,
de la jeunesse aussi,
des étudiants qui le sont.
Tous, citoyens que nous sommes,
sommes concernés par ce sujet,
donc continuer d'en parler,
de se mobiliser entre nos pairs.
Les avocats, les journalistes
doivent leur travail,
les parlementaires doivent défendre
les valeurs démocratiques
quand on voit qu'on a un pacte
des autocrates aujourd'hui
et que la démocratie recule.
C'est comme ça qu'on parviendra
à être forts dans ce qu'on défend,
dans nos valeurs.
-Le représentant
de la république iranienne
a été nommé en mai dernier
à la présidence du forum social
du Conseil des droits de l'homme
de novembre prochain.
On pourrait croire
à une blague du Gorafi.
-Oui, c'est là où on voit
qu'effectivement,
les institutions internationales
touchent parfois à leurs limites.
Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que la classe politique
se mobilise d'une manière générale
pour montrer qu'il y a
des contradictions qui sont fortes
entre la diplomatie
des droits humains...
J'entends par exemple çà et là
nos diplomates,
et c'est tout à leur honneur,
dire qu'il y a aujourd'hui
une diplomatie féministe,
en tout cas une volonté
d'une diplomatie féministe
de l'Union Européenne,
et plus largement
des sociétés démocratiques.
Cette diplomatie féministe
se heurte
à une grande contradiction.
-A la realpolitik
qui s'assoit sur ces principes
au nom d'intérêts supérieurs.
-Alors,
ça, je trouve que c'est intéressant,
la realpolitik.
On se déshonore à chaque fois
qu'on met en contradiction
des intérêts supérieurs qui seraient
les intérêts de la nation,
des intérêts économiques
et les droits humains.
Tout le monde a toujours intérêt,
et c'est l'intérêt supérieur,
à ce que les droits humains
soient respectés.
Il ne faut pas mettre en opposition
ces deux éléments.
La première condition
de la négociation
face à des régimes autocratiques
et dictatoriaux, c'est de dire :
"La négociation, oui,
mais la première des conditions,
"c'est le respect
des droits humains.
"Ensuite, on discute."
-Si ce n'est que l'Union Européenne
n'a pas inscrit
les gardiens
de la révolution
comme organisation terroriste.
C'est décevant.
-C'est une bataille
que nous avions menée
au niveau
du Parlement européen.
Nous avions mobilisé
les parlementaires
pour qu'il y ait le vote
d'une résolution qui a été votée.
C'est en ça que les parlementaires
sont courageux
et qu'il y a une forme
de diplomatie parlementaire.
Quand les exécutifs
sont un peu à la traîne,
on mobilise
les parlementaires.
Une résolution avait été votée
par le Parlement européen
pour que les gardiens
de la révolution,
bras armés des mollahs,
soient inscrits à la liste
des entités terroristes.
Le chef de la Commission européenne,
Josep Borrell, avait expliqué
qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de considérations juridiques
qui faisaient obstacle
à ce qu'on inscrive les gardiens.
En réalité, on n'est pas dupes.
La technique juridique
n'a jamais été un obstacle
quand il y a une volonté politique.
-Donc elle n'est pas là.
-Aujourd'hui, la volonté politique
n'est pas d'inscrire les gardiens
à la liste des entités terroristes,
alors que nous savons
que ce corps armé paramilitaire
est une source de déstabilisation
au Moyen-Orient,
finance un certain nombre
d'organisations terroristes,
le Hezbollah,
et est un facteur-clé
de la répression interne
et que les milices des bassidjis
qui sont une émanation des gardiens
sont aux avant-postes
de cette répression.
-Vous faites tout cela
bénévolement.
Comment trouver le temps
de collecter des preuves
quand on exerce
tous les jours au pénal ?
-Ecoutez, c'est une question...
C'est une vraie question.
C'est un devoir, je crois,
déontologique.
Je le disais souvent,
pour moi,
être avocat,
c'est deux choses.
C'est l'amour
de la condition humaine.
Quand on est avocat,
il faut aimer les gens,
il faut aimer les autres,
il faut aimer ceux qui sont acculés,
qui ne peuvent pas être défendus.
Le peuple iranien, aujourd'hui,
d'une certaine manière,
a besoin d'être défendu.
Et c'est la lutte.
Etre avocat...
Le deuxième mot qui définirait
ma profession, c'est la lutte.
La lutte au quotidien
dans les prétoires,
c'est de défendre nos clients,
et la grande lutte
en l'occurrence pour moi,
c'est la cause des femmes.
-Est-ce que c'est votre façon
de participer
au soulèvement
d'un peuple ?
-Oui, alors,
toutes proportions gardées,
avec la modestie, on apporte
notre pierre à l'édifice
et je crois que ce qui est
intéressant, c'est de dire
que le peuple iranien
est engagé dans cette lutte
et nous, ce que nous faisons,
à notre niveau,
ce n'est que de participer
à ce qu'ils font.
Un mot peut-être
et après, j'en termine,
mais les prisonnières politiques
iraniennes,
les femmes qui se mobilisent
en détention...
La prison politique d'Evin
regorge d'intellectuelles,
de militantes
des droits humains qui luttent
contre la lapidation
et la peine de mort.
Narges Mohammadi,
par exemple,
qui est une
de vos consoeurs journalistes
qui a obtenu le prix de l'Unesco
pour la liberté de la presse,
continue ces combats
depuis la détention.
Elle fait parvenir un certain nombre
de rapports sur la torture blanche
de ses camarades dans la détention.
Ces femmes m'inspirent
par leur combat et nous ne sommes
que leurs serviteurs,
et si notre travail
peut servir leur cause,
c'est avec plaisir qu'on le fait.
-La lutte féministe
vous a amenée
à monter ce collectif ?
-C'est surtout ce qui m'a amenée,
déjà, à exercer ma profession.
C'est la lecture
de "La cause des femmes"
de Gisèle Halimi qui est une avocate
qui a mené des combats féministes.
Elle m'a amenée
dans la profession d'avocat
et effectivement,
la lutte féministe
des femmes iraniennes,
c'est quelque chose
qui parle même à ma génération.
Nous...
Quand je dis "nous",
avocates de ma génération,
on a été bercées du récit
de grandes avocates
comme Gisèle Halimi
et surtout de ce récit,
qui est une réalité
des femmes enfermées
à l'univers du domestique,
du culturel, sur des lois
qui sont des lois patriarcales
et en Iran,
ce sont des lois patriarcales
qui asservissent les femmes,
qui les empêchent de prendre
leur place dans la société,
qui les excluent
d'un certain nombre de métiers,
qui les spolient
patrimonialement,
et je crois que ce récit
de la femme enfermée,
c'est ce qui fait
que les avocates que nous sommes
ont envie de briser
les murs de l'enfermement.
-Vous avez appris récemment
que vous n'étiez pas née française.
Vous avez été naturalisée
à 8 ans,
mais vous ne l'avez appris
qu'au moment de passer le barreau.
C'est quand même un comble
pour une avocate spécialisée
dans le droit des étrangers !
-C'est une anecdote que mes amis
se plaisent à raconter.
Effectivement,
j'ai appris
en révisant les règles
de la nationalité
que je n'étais pas née française.
Ce n'est pas un grand drame,
mais c'est vrai
que dans la construction
d'une identité
qu'on peut se faire,
ça vient bouleverser
un certain nombre de choses,
et c'est ce qui a fait aussi,
mon entrée dans une iranité
peut-être plus forte,
et avec un lien peut-être
plus charnel, plus intime,
avec l'origine
de mes parents.
-Au Mali,
un proverbe bambara dit :
"Si éloigné soit le jour,
il finira par arriver."
Je vous le souhaite.
-Je vous remercie.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA